what is it you like to talk about  my patient  hi  i know you're nervous i just want to  have a chat  i'm seeing something no one else can see  except for me it's smiling at me  [Music]  yesterday a patient in your care died  brutally in front of you  i need to find an explanation for what  happened  at me  it's smiling at me  [Music]  [Music]  i found 20 cases involving 19 victims of  the direct line linking them all  together  [Applause]  you said only 19  why is it that everybody else who's seen  it is dead in your life  [Music]  today's my fourth day i am not gonna  keep running  i have to face it  how does it make you feel  [Music]  [Applause]  i'm just really scared that something  bad is going to happen  [Applause]  you